It's like oh you want to stream you're allowed to pick your stream but when you hit go live
you have to wait oh hi y'all everyone welcome to the stream it's me and my favorite scots
there are many scottish people in the world i'm her favorite thank you very much
morning good evening good afternoon you know how the drill you know the drill boys you know the
drill i wrote reeflings behave reeflings and snippet snippets we we exchanged little hands today
a tentacle and a hand has been exchanged for mersey and strawney are together so hello snippets
and hello reeflings today we're gonna play untitled goose game yeah um we are obviously
expo we're mlg xbox players so we're playing on controller have no idea if that makes a difference
to this game but that's not going to stop us at all like so um we can jump right into it
thank you barrels for the five i'm a barrel thank you for the five for mersey that's going
in or moving out fun thank you for fun we were trolling i was like you do not have to mute
whenever you want to say like thank you to someone who like tips you on stream or anything like that
you don't have to mute if anything i'll join in and say thanks because it's funny like that i find
it entertaining yeah i'll thank you for the 10 10 gifted members as well thank you 10 gifted members
thank you you did it okay okay are we jumping in are you ready yeah i'm ready i'm ready i'm ready
okay let's make sure which one's me which one's you i am i'm the orange one you're the red one
wait oh thank you why you thought automatically is that lag wait we're moving together i think
we're moving together whoa we are i'm not doing that wait but i am doing 360s on the spot thank you
eternity for the for the 20 super chat on moving out fun say less less at 30
wait left trigger is this because of is this because we're so mersey
a beautiful uh did they know you're canadian yeah yeah they know okay mersey's canadian
connecting to the internet but left trigger left trigger oh my god this game is lagging out
this game is lagging out it's not working user peaks
oh my god wrinkle bell jingle bell give me the boot i will take this way
okay oh my god wait i see you're controlling me right now when you do that oh my gosh bend down
to pick things up off the ground hold bend down to toes and just slide to the rhythm of the dance
go wow i got a can oh you're picking up later can i jump oh my god hold a it makes you zoom
oh my god the lag is so bad but that's not gonna stop me we are we are monsters
oh my god i can't get it oh my god i'm so smart right drop it oh my god oh we're so smart
i don't think the farmer's gonna appreciate that to be honest i'm glad oh we can oh my god
wings press right trigger to spread oh my god we're like little babies
oh my god do you hear that music too i do not hear the music what the heck
you don't have any game sound wait why don't i have any game sound oh no is it because i'm
um no no no is it give me a second okay i think you should hear ambience i can stream it to you
via discord so you have any game sound i think my volume for the game is just low because i can hear
it but it's very shiny someone's asking a goose for goose girl for gen two absolutely no no um i
will reject your suggestions for gen two live don't think i won't i why don't i have sounds
i don't i i can share on this guild if you want and then i think i'll be like behind them possibly
i mean we can try and see what happens this is a terrible idea if i share no goose girl no slime
girl wow they're so sad i don't everyone wants slain girl am i missing some also share application
audio yes go live right check out discord and see if you can hear okay okay okay
oh on mouse is actually a lot easier oh i can't believe it i won't use mouse i'm an xbox gamer
you know hold on let me hear me honking why can't i hear it is it my is it me
that's come by the problem hold on hold on i got this i got this maybe my god there's
i'm good it's a scottish game can't believe we're in scotland there's tartan down in the bottom corner
okay i think mercy's controller is registering as both players if you're using remote play
that's hilarious because i can still control me but mercy can control both of us how in
lore friendly is that yes mercy you can control me at any time oh my gosh oh wait no i'm siren
wait a minute yeah apparently your controller input is changing into mine i'm the one that's
supposed to be hypnotizing you here what the heck the lore the lore i've been i have no idea why it's
not what is the shade on dish cold stream paused swap your application to continue strumming
oh hold on i need to go into my steam settings
oh no it's me mercy it's me sniff snifflings snifflings
the snifflings must wait as we are we are we are doing make it double prepare for
trouble someone says prepare everyone says prepare for trouble and make it double
strongy thank you iron reaper for the 25 dollar tippy with
did you see that yeah 25 as well yeah like a oh my god protect the wearer from devastation
i'm so sorry right hold on it's me it's me it's me i'm fucking up the game
i'm done it's okay enable advanced host options i play audio okay and if i wait how about now
you hear something now or don't you isn't going through my freaking i'm worried it's going through my
my um my your headset my my controller your controller can talk
bye strongy thank you for the super chat 20 super chat moving out fun towel but i
move these funds over to my darling kohai thank you wow i think oh my gosh i'm so i'm so
what's what's the words they used to say in the day pega oh pega yes i don't know where you're
going with that right okay i can close that because that doesn't look right okay it says i
am streaming the remote play audio to you now whether or not that's true or not maybe a fib or
you know that you're senpai senpai i'm a little goosling short thank you peonish for the i don't
know what this currency is id r id r id r i don't know what the dominican republic
wait what i don't know don't forget that's when you move to kibak at tabernac
oh tabernac kubacos kubacos kubac
mersey and emi were making fun of me for the way i say kubac and i'm like i say kubac kubac
sweet yeah when i say how it spell i say kubac okay for some reason the volume's just not working
on my end it's kind of weird okay and the and the stream i mean i was going to say we can play
power washer but mersey gets first person motion sick so we actually can't quite play power washer
the way others might this danie reset reset are we lobby i have no idea i have streamed the game
audio to you so i don't know why your discord discord can't hear the audio as well my discord
can't hear the audio and oh i the monitor sound is as high as it can and if it if i make it any higher
you're going to you're going to sound a lot i'm going to be a bit too much now don't get me wrong
i do appreciate stop streaming simply turn turn on webcam i said turn on webcam i don't think mersey
wants to see that first thing in the morning i'm going to be honest um if i can move this up maybe
you know i wish there was a way to like separate audio between like this i actually like the voice
caller you totally didn't notice that oh i totally didn't notice that's actually because i fucked up
right untill this game also share application audio yes at mersey right go live and then go on
discord and open up that stream that i've just given you if that does not give you the audio i
am stumped for what we're supposed to do okay oh i can hear it can senpai's hear that it might be a
little low i heard it it's such a quiet honk oh boy you can hear moe quonk okay hold on let me
wait if it's too quiet i wonder why it's too quiet
how about that how about that it's still quiet but it's here they said it's a little low
the tiniest honk oh no i can't move my volume any any higher either that's the problem
um maybe if i can move the monitor sound up
i mean i could do it one more time one more time needs to celebrate i can
okay do you hear that bell i heard a bell the tolling bell is coming for us
okay yeah input for some reason mersey can also control me in the game i don't i don't know how
you've managed that but we have
bike i took control i can literally i can retake control of myself if i want but every
time you move i'm fighting against you in your pool yandere like holy crap you've literally
main broken me to do thy bidding and i'm not supposed to be the hypnosis here everywhere
we're supposed to play under these conditions quick let's make a heart with our with our beats i
don't know uh i can face you like this
i forgot about the honk again x oh wait
right we've completely forgotten wait there is a picnic down here it looked like uh scotland
look it's scotland oh oh wait our wings are up because the things were going to war but we're not
oh i don't know what your your your anthem is oh my god let's give it a huggy little hug huggy
i can't really hug you because every time you move towards me it pushes me away from you
because of the controls her powers of attraction with our wings out we literally look like wait
you control my wings as well my i copy everything how have we done this i have no idea i don't
think i've ever seen this girl work it is this what is supposed to happen
i'm playing with an extra challenge oh this i have no idea what this game is about by the way
so this will be interesting b is to open stuff so oh my gosh nate thank you for the gift of 10
holy crap thank you oh mercy is discovering i appreciate that ned but you're supposed to
give it to mercy because she's moving out stuff stuff oh my god we're doing gardening
gardening hold left one for as amount oh there's a man across the wall do you see him yeah yeah yeah
can i can i jump can we are you gonna you want to put the water on yeah wait why is he coming out
to us we're getting jumped we're getting jumped right can we open up this fence ah shit no is logged
from the other side wait can geese no fly what's going on here oh i keep mo you push me into the
secret you push me into the hedge secret i don't know how you did that but i'm so good i didn't know
i could do it i'm literally i'm not good control this is amazing
i'm i'm gonna jump them i'm jumping them
why no no no no leave leave mercy alone she's discovering a box she's not
playable
okay okay but where are we supposed to put the keys i don't know oh i guess we just run with the keys
i mean wait how do we know what that checklist is i saw stuff oh my god i'm fighting against
mercy so much right now trying to control myself again oh this is a problem on purpose
be be be oh i'm getting jumped he's jumping me he's jumping us
we got it we got it you got it okay let's run i'm going i'm going i don't know i'm gonna go back to
the fence yeah get through the fence right is this oh get to the fence oh okay success
how or what do we do with the is my question oh we cause problems on purpose
okay now we take it uh where oh make the groundskeeper wear his sun hat okay
right where did i say rake in the lake all right have a picnic okay we can do that rake in a lake
yeah okay we can do that right uh i is there a rake in the garden yeah there is
oh wait is maybe the key is for the fence that was over here don't you dare use that to trap me you fool
he wouldn't do that is he a mean i don't think he's me oh the gate's already open where the heck is
a rake oh there's the rake you've got it how did i pick up again a b b b b if we're going
for a pic yeah b like press left trigger b left trigger b trigger b yeah i'm stealing the goods
i got the i got the goods for the picnic don't worry get the foods on me no no no leave mercy alone
she's almost gone give me the color give me this no leave
i'm totally fighting against i'm fighting against i mean just have things that it's still i leave my
mercy alone wait no no there's the i don't think you can get it i think you have to push it through
the oh i'm now just following you out this what i'm stuck
okay the game is there's a there's a there's a gate here that you can pull it from
i don't think we can do it through the fence we must be wise we must be oh so smart now i'm stuck
in there i'm stuck in there oh thank you he saw tall for the 50 super didn't catch the bit about
moving out at the start i was afk but this should be good for moving out money right thank you so much
yeah give me this give me the right wait is that actually stuck wait wait can he pick it up
oh can you pick up the ring can you pick up okay thank goodness whoa whoa he pushed you through
right okay that's good there's a gate down here i assume we grab the i like how he's just watching
this cause me he made him but he's like happy to just let us go by he's like what if these kids
how do we can we open that yeah i was gonna say can you reach up and open that or is it no open it
for us open for us oops this there's a hammer on top of the wall that seems dangerous actually
wait maybe we can go on this chair yeah let me move this chair over if i if i fight the tide
i'm fighting the i'm so strong no the chair doesn't move okay okay maybe you can go on the chair
i don't think we have the ability to jump we can open our wings but it's the best i can do
i can open my wings you get through the gate by doing the tasks on the list oh my god okay so
we're region locked right now okay okay okay we got it i am hey cannot believe i somehow managed
to get your controller input oh okay we pull it out here got it got it you gotta get yes we gotta
get the the rake where is it i don't see him right we're grabbing it let's go let's get the heck out
here okay come come come this way this way this way uh you can pull me you can like pull us both
yeah yeah remember you can pull me oh no oh no he's like right there no no no no it's not
what it looks like it's not what it looks like give me that rake it's not it's not what it looks
like sir stop stop but i demand by the in the name of the okay guys here get the rake get the rake
get the rake get the rake you can do it left trigger b left trigger b push me down push me down
nice no give me that let's leave it no don't you close that gate we need to open give me that
give me it oh there's lots about his own garden right drop the gate you don't need it
give me this you don't need it and you don't have keys now what like let go i will let me go
yeah yeah yeah yes right oh yes yes yes you want it so badly don't you yes you do yes you want it
so badly no okay wait wait wait wait no give me the rake take that fertilizer mercy pick up pick up
i'm trying i'm trying right yeah yeah oh sugar i'm so gonna get out the way get out the way
why are we so coordinated okay we made progress we made progress i'll take it okay let me pick up
this fertilizer oh my god it's because of the input wait if i disconnect if i disconnect my controller
is it gonna oh i don't want to reset i i don't want to actually reset us no don't go in
oh i'm gonna drop the sandwich how do i drop it oh there you go yeah yeah we need to do a picnic
right yes right drop the rake yes you care so much about this that's good i don't care about it leave
me alone okay if you get the rake i'll pick up the fertilizer if i can fight against it wait let me
put the fertilizer in my mouth okay i'm holding the fertilizer he should come to me now you pick
up the rake you pick up the rake you can do it you can do it yeah shove in the lake get that rake
in the lake get that rake in the lake he takes it off me so quickly oh okay we're doing it we're
doing it we're doing it oh hello yes yes yes yes yes yes yeah easy easy if you make the other
player player one that should fix it um i actually it took us quite a miracle to get into this game
not gonna lie uh i might just let mercy control me and open my wings i will take where the wind
glides me the wind is gliding me to this gate i hopefully i'll be fixed um in the next round is
it rounds i don't even know how many maps there are okay let's see if i can help out here uh our
foods how much do we need for the game to oh i missed it's okay take it in
that wasn't it bring to the picnic a pumpkin a carrot jam tomato radio
oh there i was gonna say i was like nah that doesn't look like a tomato to me
right do we need to go through the fence we do we'll probably have to go through the
the tiny little thing again there's only one map this game was so expensive and you're telling me
there was one map we love causing problems on purpose all right all right i'm in a better
hunker i said it uh these are the cabbages right was that a pumpkin i thought it was a pumpkin
do we need pumpkins or cabbages i'm gonna grab this one
okay i got it no i don't want to let the farmer back in
see if you can go through the thing
so the gate himself oh he just opened the gate okay
wait can we not be off screen at the same time
oh wow we can oh i didn't realize i'm pushing you off the screen and you're it's okay i'm
following you there you go okay yes we need pumpkin i don't know if there's like jam in the
garden somewhere i need probably but you got the pumpkin uh yes we can mark pumpkin off the
what is this a monument i'm at oh it is a monument it's like a little shrine oh wow okay the gate
was open i did not have to go all of that way but uh do you want to pick up a carrot while you're
there we needed a carrot for the the i want to kill it yeah are we kill it i want to kill it let
hello let's trigger me yeah that's it let's trigger me
it's probably i'm not gonna lie we're probably ice skating as well on top because of the lag
wait he took the carrot off of you he took the carrot off me what a bastard share your garden with me
i literally there's always enough for both the
i'm not gonna have to distract him i think i am hold on let me get this one
give us the carrot give us the carrot give it back it's not yours
oh i got it i got it i got it i'm stuck in the lawnmower wait
grab the carrot no no pick it up oh my god no i'm getting manually over read by the freaking input
i'm stuck i'm stuck i'm stuck no no give it back give it back you smell give it back that's mine
look if it goes on the picnic thing then it's mine
literally oh i see the jam gosh can we even reach that
i will flood your garden now
and i would oh no he's going for the pumpkin leave the pumpkin out of this
you have goose in your garden oh no no no you're not alone
right well if you're gonna do that at least give me the
need the carrot
i took his head
oh no i have terrible news i think we're actually gonna have to reset
i don't think i can play with these controls
okay it's okay i'm willing to reset
yes okay we can probably speedrun this to be honest i have no idea
so hold on i'm gonna hide my game just in case i show anything that shit i'm not
i need to hide my game input uh
if i quit and then invite you on local co-op that should work right sure
i'm gonna hide my game too just in case my game capture now sometimes can't can't you can't see
do funny things oh you've done mouse and keyboard did you mean to do that
wait no that was me that did that was you it was yes it was me i was like
hmm you did that so fast mercy i don't remember inviting you hmm
i think it's because we're still there are you still in this instance
or did i need to send you a new instance
no that was you that was that was you okay i think it should be fine now
okay hold on all right you move around
and let's get out of this bush first oh yeah they are blind hold on what
dream capture gooski i will wow how bizarre
wait is this like is this a bug
how strange right i'm just going to do mouse and keyboard give me one more shot mercy one more
shot okay one more shot give me one more chance i will do mouse and keyboard and because i think
that's what's clashing for some random reason take that out i don't need that in my pc
okay begin two player i would like to use mouse and keyboard and i will use i may use controller
okay we did it you need to probably swap who player one is i was player one last time i think
okay space bar is honk i mean you need to quickly relearn all of the
maybe are we the only one's an experience to ever have this bug before
this is crazy oh my god game literally unplayable do you think i can get a refund
how right how did i make you am i am i one more powerful give me literally give me one more chance
i'm on my knees give me one more chance is all i ask can you okay another suggestion was to start
you go first controller off and then join in okay we're trying we're trying okay
controller off join in this is the most bizarre there's only two of us and you want to get them
get them boys take that man's carrots right now okay i mean okay your game controller
i will do mouse and keyboard i will play it safe i am on mouse and keyboard mercy is player one
as evidence by oh i'm the red one now okay use the mouse wait to click are we are we
separate people now i think we are i'm separate okay we can actually cause some mayhem let's go
press control yeah okay i've played college before you don't have to tell me to us
okay we can actually play now
only took us 30 minutes to be able to play but now we are unstoppable literally
uh head uh oh wait it's not like wasd i keep accidentally like zooming in and out like really
dramatically
kiss time kiss time we love troubles and oh you guys are blind sorry i forgot you guys are
blind sorry sorry it was just straight up playing the game without you guys seeing sorry
i love scrawny cuddles i feel like they're so clumsy who's the porno stuff them all
mirror mirror on the wall who is the one of them all he will sell the picnic for a
that i actually i'm inclined to believe that's true that mercy is the point is that it was all
but i think that's adorable i mean come on a dorky and dairy this pond how are you supposed to
how are you supposed to resist yeah how are you supposed to resist senpai exactly
what kind of signage is it's got green on it please serve my venus sandwich yeah okay there we go
i hope there's no mayonnaise in this i'm allergic well yeah you can't have eggs like any kind of egg
primarily how do you have none of the cloth here too wait come back come back no not you i mean me
oops i made him wet okay so we have to make them wet okay this must be the radio so i'm
gonna grab that we need it yeah at the picnic thing oh may i yes oh if i had aim bought i oh i keep
doing wasd it's not w i'm having a stroke it's not wasd i need to take my fingers off the keys
right uh crouch yes we got it wait it distracts him wow yeah unlock that gate
oh that range honk stop making noise little thing
stop making noise it's gonna give it away i don't oh no why did i pick the heart well maybe we
can grab the jam or something while we're at it hold on let's grab the jam let's grab the jam
or key or carrots or anything right jam jam jam jam it was like up here right here
give me a can you reach i'm tiny when y'all i can grab this i feel like he's gonna notice me
grabbing such a lot yeah he's gonna see me grab the carrot first though hey well let's get the carrot
first any progress is good progress you take the carrot i'll see if i can grab a pumpkin
where am i where am i oh i lost myself there we go come on come on i've got the pumpkin
this is freaking much more than the hell
we didn't need any back
okay this game is not easy it's really not easy this is kind of hard to control
i'm literally having a stroke right now i'm like keep using wasd but it's for freaking
zooming in and out for some reason right you got the carrot i need his keys give me them keys
oh no you took it off wait how did you take it off me i just grabbed them
this is so hard to control me oh hold on let me see what's going on over here
i'm trying to get the thermals there we go oh you want to look at me no no no you want to
look at me no no no leave leave me alone i'm so freaking slow at this game leave her alone leave
her alone leave her alone leave her alone give me your leave me your own nope you don't want the
thermals oh sorry i'm i'm going to not something else yeah wait he let me join the keys yeah
get out get out get out get out oh this is so hard hold on hold on i can't move
i'm missing the door door the impossible door's done door's done
uh where'd i put the keys i don't even know i'll put them by the gate why not put them like
way over here so if he does come out he goes like right here yeah what do you mean what
what do you mean sam pie you're like mercy come on oh no he noticed it quick grab something else
wait he's gonna go all the way to it wait do we need to fill up the water can for him no give
me the water can't look i can fill up the water can for you look it's like teamwork come on we love
after we love after culture oh oh wait whoa i got the job i got the job picking up picking up picking
oh and i'm completely messing it up oh my god i forgot about the ring oh
i got the job no no i got it oh god he's coming he's coming no i'm locked out because of the
freaking render distance no no sir sir give me the jam you want me no no sir i'll grab something
else we'll grab something else hold on hi yeah you know we need it for a picnic you don't understand
i can't i can't speak human language i can only hold violently just give me the job honestly if a
bird you're here oh no oh no i'm trying
leave me to the job right we'll do the rake maybe the rake in the lake yeah we've
been the rake in the lake why that's my radio pick up pick up the jam why is the jam not
why is the rum always gone why is it was a mistake it's not really thievery if you don't
need it you wouldn't know is it gone you can always get a new one honk violently does it just
stun lock them if you honk grab the jam i got it i got it i got it i'm out i'm out i'm out i'm out
we're freedom yeah freedom okay uh i can't go you getting pushed off of it while he's holding it
oh my god we did it we actually got the jam we got the jam like a billion other things to do
so one was like it's one map apparently but there's five sections i have no idea if i'm smart
enough to do all five sections um but we could try what smartness do we need we have like
brains the size of i don't know like a peanut what do we oh sorry what does it say have a picnic
rake in the lake we just need our radio okay if we need to rake in the lake then don't mind me
i'm grabbing this excuse me uh you'd come over me
uh excuse me sir sorry excuse me uh have you thought about maybe not
i love the honk feature sir please have you considered the radio no
okay can i escape like this no stop standing leave
this is impossible sure i'm sure there's like a speed run strategy and someone's like done it in
like 18 minutes flat nothing else i think we're it's because we're having problems with the controls
oh i mean progress progress the rake is getting closer to the lake nope stop it
stop it i want the rake give me the rake don't you shoot me away give me the rake here here i
distract him oh i got it i got it no my radio ah this definitely should be a split screen game
because i literally cannot progress until you come right game devs that's a point down game devs
for not letting me uh co-op player progress we got we got it we got it and then okay he's not
chasing after us so we're safe there we go and last but oh can i release yes please uh last but
certainly not least the radio now if i just honk at him and distract him
all right now uh hello i am mr goose i would like to teach you all those things about geese
did you know that geese are very good people and we are not stealing your large container at all
behind me please do not look behind me um i don't need your radio or you got the radio no no no no
there's no no there's no radio please listen to me thank you for listening to my so conversations
about geese did you know that we're actually very good avian birds and that um our feet our feet
actually transformed into flippers to help with us glading when it comes to the war um
you know we have we have we have we have we have we have we have corkscrews corkscrews please
let me teach you about the corkscrews sir oh please it's really important
okay okay yes yes look at me look at me look at me look at me yes yes yes yes right come on
left trigger b to pick up the radio i'm out i'm picking up the door please listen to my corkscrew
rent so did you know that uh female ducks unfortunately um in when it comes to nature when
it comes to nature sir please just a moment of your time when it comes to nature when it comes to
nature um female ducks actually can't um you know reject unfortunately because of the dog eat dog
okay thank you for your time goodbye we did it we did it we did it
we can enjoy your picnic together oh we can do what you have in first to eat
i think i'm gonna have uh the pumpkin your pumpkin uh i'm gonna have good jam and bread
is that actually bagpipes
kind of sounds like a big oh wait i can hear the snare drum and the drone which makes me
think this is genuinely bagpipe music oh no oh no this can't be it is oh well we completed our
objective whoa sorry sorry that was me make the ground keeper hammer his thumb
what oh um well well we had our little picnic yeah um i'm not sure how we do that
and we waddled away waddle waddle till the very next part of the mission bomb bomb bomb
the geese walked up to the gardener's garden and they said to the man
want to learn about cork screws hey bum bum bum let us steal your well no geese sign
hey you said no geese this is geesist yeah this is geesist how do i make him hammer his thumb
i'm not sure anyways i'm gonna do some guiding now it's my garden it's our garden
oh are you starting a farm yeah what would you grow what would you grow i must
grow strawberries because they're easy
how do we get him he's not hammering did we just watch him do what he wants to do
he's not hammering anything oh maybe he's gonna hammer the sign where would i if i was a mean
farmer where would i put the sign yeah where are you gonna put it show me
yeah where are you gonna put it man are you gonna put it you got shows oh oh okay he's getting the
hammer next so i need to get out of the way excuse me sorry i'll get out of the way i guess when
we have her's just honk get ready steady
oh no no okay okay we wait ready
yes okay okay that makes sense that makes sense yeah whoa we made a pass out are you okay
okay we're free we're free we're the now now we're we're we're in other territory
the tutorial is finished we are now actually exploring the game
wow this must this must be when we become menaces to society
we have to smart every every project starts small scale we have terrorized a per grandpa and
is retirement and brought close to a heart attack by raising his blood pressure significantly
and now we will do it to the masses oh hello football
oh my gosh tv let me in come on england honk honk please let's we have we have human
monies come to the door there is a person inside there we would like to spend our human
wealth on you are totally human money here yes it's sort of not leave something together
i found a weapon oh hello lady oh you don't seem very nice with that hey
why wow some people aren't nice to nature oh my gosh why are we why are we why are we
disliked so much wait what's on the list oh whoa break the room that's a lot
break the broom trap a boy in a phone booth what the i mean make the boy wear the wrong
glasses make someone buy back their own item get on tv get on tv and go shopping put in the basket
a toothbrush loo roll her um airbrush food cleaner fruits and veggies wow that's so much
they are i'm walking here hey i'm walking here i can hear uh how do i make
ah she like okay she completely throws you out of the area so uh there's something over here
oh no not again oh my god there's like a cute look whoa what you got there a garbage are you littering
yeah you can get oh there's apple cores there's the toothbrush right
wait you're right ooh we have to buy a new toothbrush oh i guess well i guess it's recycled
at this point then it's not used we we love environment uh i guess back at her shop if we're
supposed to buy it i don't want to put it too close to her shop in case she puts it somewhere
oh she's so nasty up there this basket no that ain't it i must be where you are
lady i get it you don't want oh that's the that's definitely a basket i don't know what they look
right oh no yeah okay this is an airplane what with an air is an airplane on the list sorry hold on
yeah sorry sorry me bad me bad airplane uh loo roll her brush tin food cleaner fruit and veg
no okay that's definitely not it is that the boy are we uh excuse me we're here to lock you inside
a phone booth oh no he's scared of us get in the phone booth get in the phone booth get in the phone
booth get in the phone booth yes there we go now we trap him inside there uh how do we trap him
oh that was it oh my god he's calling for help for his parents oh i feel really bad
oh wait his dad is right there oh wait right running when he comes out i guess
oh i love tv let me in let me in oh we both got chased out right oh what's going on in here
get on tv i'm honking i'm honking oh wait there's a button there's a button to the left of the
window do you see it okay i'll push it oh i'm trying i'm trying oh my goodness camera he's killing me
it's killing me get it get it get it get it get it oh you're going oh we're on tv oh it's us there's
oh my god we're featuring in the game my name is oh my god your face is right up to the camera
oh my god no okay we got chased out it's fine but we did what we needed to do we did it to to enemy girl
bully per child honestly oh he's bullying poor poor british child why do you see british because
it looks like a wimp oh i guess i don't know i think british are the only people that say lu paper
right oh oh yeah you're right this is a british game all right someone's to buy the wrong glasses
or something i don't know i'm gonna have to wear the wrong glasses let me take your stuff oh okay okay
yeah yeah yeah leave me alone mersey's cooking okay i got it let me see
oh no is she gonna see it oh i don't want i don't want her to see it give me those
i don't know what to do i think she's gonna see it oh wait if you put the glasses where his toy is
wait why do i want him to chase me that's his toy i don't yeah he's got a toy on the bench i want
do you put glasses on the bench
what a confusing game i have to admit i'm i'm a rather confused i don't know i like chaos
how do i how do i take glasses off of a child
you put it where the toy is oh no oh no she's not no you're not supposed to see that she took it
oh she took my glasses wait so she doesn't see the wait she needs her broom how do i make her
break her broom i don't know thank you anonymous i probably should have showed you that i was panicking
oh i've just crossed off the game oh right let's not do that again that was a bad choice
right release thank you lord yeah yeah rick i wonder what happens to the cage when some
move out of their cage when mercy moves out uh we gotta make some room right cage and have a leak
okay this is literal i guess they put it in this basket or is she gonna like be region
it's fine oh there's plants here this is so cute what else do we need the hairbrush
oh i i can't remember i can't remember oh oh i see i see why am i you can grab her broom like
the back of it wait can we rip it apart i think we can hold on let me get behind her all right
give me that broom give me that i think you'll fight you for it
like i know you ain't that strong you've been you in retail i know how
yes give me that broom that's what i think about your broom you lady
getting so good this game is an australian game in melbourne but you terrorize an english
village oh sugar we need the hairbrush and i just completely forgot and i had the perfect
opportunity to grab it because i was reading chat oopsies honest mistake honest mistake
don't poke us with a stick like what's going on here uh sorry i don't know do we
buy oh she's fixing the broom wait he just put his glasses back on
how do you put it back on why is she she's pushing me away by her aura alone
uh right so she's gonna fix the broom that's fine how do i make the child where the wrong
glasses i mean the glasses are there actually she never took the glasses back
so child do you drop the glasses if we scare you enough
no what are you doing young child i tried to which we demand you wear new glasses right now
you were giving the gift of sight oh literally it was i'm i think we're missing some sort of
timed event on him oops oh i remember how to put the glasses on him you gotta go for his shoe laces
hold on a minute enemy spotted target spotted we need to go for his shoe laces oh no those are
glicks oops sorry i just picked up the glicks i did it wait and then what we push and then we
take his glasses and give them and give them the new ones okay i comprehend all right okay the
glasses are now in the way he should look for yes yes can you give him those glasses
and then drop it in front of him yes oh we did it thank you refling we love getting our hands
okay you look better in that one anyways yeah this is red uh we need to make someone buy back
their own stuff wait did i not put loo paper in that basket airbrush in the basket loo paper
we did put in wait so red just she took it man i was trying to buy that what
she took it that's why give us give us it back what's this here i'll distract her
how did she see that she got eyes on the back of her head
like i'm just trying to support your small but local business
so then who it says we're supposed to sell someone it
oh maybe we take his plane and we put it back and you'll buy it yeah and he'll buy it maybe
hey i like that theory oh everyone everyone calm down
uh oh yeah yeah yeah you're right you're right you're right oh ah sugar ah no no no no no no no
she's not done yet she's not placed it done
wait is she gonna serve him she is i think you did it oh my god you did it right well
sir having a conversation uh i'm gonna go yank a leak because we need some veggies uh don't mind
me just waddling off yeah oh no the carcass he actually did fire i feel so bad i feel bad but
also not honk yeah i knew to do this has been added
why is the music so intense oh my god honk honk honk honk honk yonk yonk i'm stuck on the edge
i can't fit it all in the
i'm running laps around no how can you even notice she's picked something up i'm trying
to explain to you i need this tomato and you're being so rude about it you are you honestly are
all right what do we actually need go shopping tinned food a cleaner and a hair brush
trap the shopkeeper in the garage where's the garage
oh yeah you said garage don't you wait why what happens if wait she's going in the garage now
how do i trap her in honker oh oh we pull it down we pull it down oh no i was oh no
oh no
help me lady i'm stuck in your game i'm in the garage mate
uh lady question mark are you gonna come save me have i just soft locked us because of my
i'm just trying to i communicate sir that i'm stuck in here there's no way i did that
the the the objective get her stuck in it me instantly get stuck in it
is she gonna hear me can she hear me maybe oh is that the
is there something in here it's a zoom to get the camera's attention um
oh she does come and save me okay
thank goodness because please help me
okay wait until she gets inside hello come in come in come in into my secret layer hello
i am goosey my goose face i'm no no no no come in come in come in come in come in
wait unless i steal an item and run in with it
hold on hold on wait you're not coming
no i never picked it up no give it back right give me the leak
come into the garage lady come into the garage
chase me into the garage no i dropped it no i dropped the freaking thing
hard okay oh right i don't think i can get her stuck inside um what do you want
if i get her stuck inside does she reverse kidnapping hoisted hoisted by yours okay how
what hairbrush tin food cleaner hold on i'll chop her in the garage
right i can see the hairbrush i'm going for it i said i'm going for the hairbrush no i'm getting
shoved out uh okay i got a hairbrush but she's fucking gunning for me i think we need to lock
her in or we can't progress you know that hold on oh maybe if i can grab her broom she always
wants her broom and then we lock her in yeah okay i'm on standby you must chase her in oh wait
i need a honk she's so violent with me she's so fast women give me we're both fighting over
for the freaking broom okay okay i'll stop fighting no no no i don't mean like that i just
mean she's so strong too geese can't be it best or oh wait i figured out oh my god oh my god i figured
it out pick it up and run no pick it up i need to pick up that piece give me the piece or put the
piece in the garage yeah oh my god she's pushing me away she's got like a five meter radius aura
or something about her honestly oh right i've got it i've got it are you ready are you ready are you
let me run out let me run out she'll take a second to fucking
i mean oh no wait wait wait she'll open it she's doing she's doing something she's opening
he's opening his side quick oh oh there's cleaner i found the cleaner
another there we go there we go i want to clean our progress progress we're gonna be trapped it's
it's fine it's fine tempai um well this is kiosk no oh my god our peri wait why are you i just
picked this uh the trash i literally just picked this out of the trash lady leave me alone i picked
it myself thank you jake for becoming a membo i appreciate it
is there right so does it only one hair brush hair brush intend food okay okay hair brush i can
do hair brush i'm pretty sure it's like over here okay her bro her broom is in tatters so maybe she
doesn't care that much hmm she cares a little bit you're here grab it grab it grab it grab it
oh my god please game please cooperate with me a little bit oh do you want to lock her in yeah
do you want to lock her in lock her in and get ready oh shit oh no women you're only supposed
to be a looking maybe a learning literally can no give me that back give me a book her aura's too
strong she like won't she doesn't listen like other npc she's so strong and hey hey give me that
Check this over here. Look at me
Yes, that'll do at least it's progress you are a nightmare lady you really are I need something W
Aste. I'm sorry. It keeps making the camera late. Oh, please just work. Oh, thank god. We did it Jesus. We're done
We're done, okay
Oh no! Look! She drew knee ducts on this. That's really rude. I didn't even appreciate that.
No, let's get one thing straight.
Oh. Oh! Ow! Ow! Ow!
Give me that.
Oh, lady!
Oh, Azara! Thank you for the raid!
She opened up a gate. Did we go through the gate?
I think we did it.
Granny got new knees. No wonder she's so fat. Yeah.
Man, screw this place. I'm going home.
We're gonna screw this place. We need trouble anywhere else.
Mmm. You're so rude.
Azara, welcome! Welcome, Raiders! Welcome to the stream of chaos!
Why?
Uh, left or right?
Oh, you're all right?
Oh, there's a pond!
Mmm, water.
Water.
Uh...
Daily clave.
Whoa! I saw that.
I saw that.
Is there a complete Little Nightmare confirmation?
Confirmation time.
Confirmation any Little Nightmare-ers?
We love dino-nuggies.
Hello, mister.
I'm playing with your lacrosse.
Uh, well, I do objectives. Let's see what our objectives are.
Make someone break the fancy vase.
Help the woman dress up the bust.
Make the man spit out his tea.
Get dressed up with a ribbon.
Make the man go barefoot.
Do the washing.
What?!
Are we supposed to go into, like, different gardens?
Oh, wait! This is the man spit out his tea.
Um...
Yeah, here's your hat.
How do we make someone spit their tea out?
That's so specific.
Get trapped, nerd.
Okay, he keeps taking his hat back, but how do we...
Maybe if we wait for him to get his tea, and then he won't get him.
Ah, I'm off work.
Yeah, let's do that. Yeah, agreed.
Okay, let's watch this gentleman try and have his tea.
Well, hello there.
There's a lady across the fence. Hi! Are you friendly?
Probably, no.
Is anyone friendly, honestly? I don't think so.
Special rules.
Oh, ribbon!
Ta-da!
Uh, uh...
Hello?
Make her break the vase!
Oh, the vase, the vase!
See this fucking thing?
Man, fuck this thing.
I'm putting this one thing in particular. Uh, everything else.
Oh, her wee bra's on the line.
I know she got wee socks as well.
Wah.
Uh...
I'm stoke. I'm stoke.
Hello? No, no, no, no.
No, hold on. The camera movement's making me a little bit deezy.
Oh, no!
Are you feeling a bit sick?
Yeah, just give me a moment.
If you feel too sick, it's okay. We can post-trap.
I ain't gonna force you to play if you feel sick.
I didn't realize the camera was so unsteady.
Yeah, it was just like...
Aw, this is so cute.
We can just do this in the film.
She's staring at me!
Is she gonna break it?
No.
Oh! Oh my god, let me dress you up!
Okay!
Oh, wait a minute.
Wait, that's our mare's knee.
That's literally our bow. That's her entire design.
Listen, I have a bow on my chest!
Exactly.
And technically, your bow and your skirt is your skirt?
Yeah, it is on the back of your skirt, as I don't...
Oh, there's like a wee frog thing.
Oh, a little inter-
Oh, sorry, sorry, I didn't mean to...
Take your thing.
Is it a bell?
Uh, why do you even have that, lady?
Is that how we break the statue?
Does she notice I have the bow?
No, I notice she doesn't have it, I promise.
I have the soap.
Wait, this is a bathroom and...
This is a garden, it's a bathroom!
Uh, no!
This isn't a bathtub, lady.
This isn't a lifeguard's seat.
Aw, no, that's not the meme, why is it?
This is a bathtub.
This isn't a beach, it's a bathtub!
Yes, yes, that's it!
What's in the drawer?
Oh, sorry about that.
Oh, chap, didn't really mean to do that, but hey, hold on, we're here now.
I love causing problems on purpose.
Whomp, whomp.
Whomp, whomp, whomp, whomp, whomp, whomp, whomp, whomp, whomp, whomp.
I don't...
I assume I can put it on you, essentially.
But...
What a bizarre...
Come here, come here.
I can put it on you?
I thought I could put it on you.
Oh, I'm just joined it from you.
Oh, we're just passing it mathematically, excuse me.
Oh, we're just like, here you go, no, you have it, no, you have it, no, you have it.
You hang up, you hang up, you hang up.
Uh, I don't know how to get her to break this.
Um, no, she's always gonna have it.
She goes to an idol meeting in the open, literally.
How, what is, maybe we go in another garden for now.
Wait, can we even get out of here?
Wait, we can't even get out until we progress through this stage?
Our section?
There is a gate here.
Hello, Mr. Gate.
That is not going to work.
Can we put this on you?
We have...
I don't know if you can.
I like the way we both look down at it.
We're like, hmm, hmm, that's not the way it should be.
Okay, why can I not put it on you?
Oh, oh, oh, you're so aggressive.
No, I'm like trying so hard to put it on you right now.
Maybe, oh, wait, wait, wait, oh, maybe if I move the duck, if we move the geese.
And you be the duck?
Yeah, and I'll be the, I'll be the inch.
Oh, I like this idea.
And then I stand there and then she puts it on me.
Unless you're going to constantly put it.
Okay, right, I'll let her pick that up.
And then I'm going to yank this away.
No, you don't care about this.
Okay, look, it's hidden.
No, I just clicked off the game and you stopped doing that.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, grab the ribbon, grab the ribbon.
Where is it?
I'm trying.
Oh, no, you've got me, lady.
Wait, does she know that?
Yeah.
She knew.
That was.
I want the ribbon.
Wait, what?
How does she know that's not possible?
What is on me?
Fine.
But the game literally says to put her there.
The table we broke, something about the table we broke.
Hold on, what's up with the table?
We're looking at our table now.
This one.
Oh, it's how we get out.
We go up the table now to go into another garden.
Oh, OK.
You're going to move on to the next one and we can come back to this.
We'll come back to the garden as soon as we share the mister.
We call her Miss Crackpot because we have to crack her pot.
Hi.
Do you have a cup of tea by any chance for us little geeseling?
We really like your lacrosse.
We do.
Do you want to have some tea, a bit of tea?
No, no tea.
OK, jeez.
It's hard to impress these people, clearly.
Does he have a sip of tea, maybe?
Come on, let's watch him.
Hello.
Hello?
He doesn't.
He really looking at us like, can I help you?
Yeah, actually, you're a mission objective.
We're not doing it.
We're not up to no good.
No.
I'm just I'm just crouching around in your garden.
I ain't doing nothing.
We're doing what we watched.
We're watched through the fence.
He can't see us, but we can see him.
We're we're such we're such bad geese.
Literally.
What is going on?
Night night.
Wait, why is he so?
Why is he so suspicious?
But yeah, he's paranoid.
He like can't even enjoy his tea.
Come on, drink your tea, sir.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
He's rubbing his knees.
Rubbing his knees.
Yeah.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
No, you're supposed to spell it, my good sir.
Did I not give you a fright doing that?
All right, take a sip.
Take it.
Hey.
Wait, that was what we wanted?
Wait, we wanted him to spit out the tea,
so he has to drink the whole thing, I think.
Was that not it?
No.
Steal his shoes.
Don't have to tell me to it.
Hi.
Oh, no, I didn't mean to do that.
I meant to steal your loafers, sir.
Sorry.
Yeah, I'm geeny, damn loafers.
Go sit down, sir.
Go sit down.
I want your shoes.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, he didn't like that.
Look at him.
He's taller.
Like, he's taller-y in us, but he's kind of not.
Uh, what?
No.
Oh, no, I missed my turn.
There, can't get enough, can you?
Sucker.
No, run.
Yeah.
Out of bounds.
That's right.
You aren't coded to come over here.
Only I'm coded to come over here, but you?
No.
Oh, did he just boot me because I took his shoe?
You don't deserve it.
Maybe use the big bell behind him.
Oh!
That makes perfect sense, actually, to do the bell when he goes for a sip.
Can we see him do a sip from that side?
One of us has to go on the other side, I think.
I think we, uh, I think we both have to do it or else we can, and...
We're back!
America Kayo, hello!
There he is.
Excuse me, madam.
I need the bell.
You're in my way, madam.
Madam, please refrain from getting in my way.
Right.
Oh, sorry.
Okay, that's definitely what you're supposed to do when he sips his tea.
We just need to hang around while he does his tea.
Okay, we're getting there.
We just need our handheld through the game.
Just a tiny bit.
Okay, just a tiny bit of hand-holding.
Right, so we need to wait until he's suspicious.
This is over.
He shouldn't.
He should drink his tea after he's done his, like, suspicious animation.
Oh, I'm trapped.
I'm trapped.
We're good.
I didn't...
This game is a lot harder than I thought.
I thought this was like a...
I say this about every game I play.
Oh, I thought this was a child's game.
Why is it hard?
Right, we're like, why is it hard?
Why is it...
No, the bell thing needs to be set up again.
She's not fixing it.
Oh, no.
You're right.
Oh, sugar.
What is she trying to fix right now?
She's currently painting.
I don't know.
I can take her painting brush.
Oh, I can draw her painting brush, one or the other.
Oh, wow.
Good night, Straniaga.
I'll wake up in four hours, bro.
You are going to be shattered.
Um, no.
Was I supposed to take the paper?
Oh, she's going to fix the bell.
Okay.
And then...
Do you want to put the duck in the other garden?
I wonder if that's what it is.
You put the statue in the other garden,
so then she forgets she even had a duck.
No.
No, no, no, no.
I must tell you...
Okay, there we go.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, it's now out of bounds,
so she can't ask for the duck anymore.
It doesn't work like that.
And now we wait for him to drink his dang tea
that must be frozen solids at this stage.
Because there's no way.
Please ask for tea.
Are you coming in this garden?
Yeah.
Your audio may be cutting out from me
on Discord a little bit.
Oh, sorry.
No, that was all good, the knee already.
So she knows it's fake, right?
She tells you to move.
Do I need to paint you?
So she's fixing that.
Wait, can I put the bull on you now
because we got rid of the statue?
No, I've done...
You didn't give me time.
Right, go paint.
Whoa!
Jeez.
Let's do this bail.
I want some bourbon.
This German.
Oh, he's about to do his animation.
Okay.
No, no, no, wait.
No!
He was supposed to do the drink tea animation.
Why?
Maybe this will help your mindset for the puzzle.
The game is meant to single player.
Everything can be done solo.
You mean we could be doing this twice as fast
but it's taken us three times as long?
Hold on a minute.
What's going on here?
These allegations.
Are you calling us dumb?
Why?
Because you're right.
Cush me.
Yeah, I mean, it's not.
Wait, water in this dish maybe?
I'm like trying to look around for hints,
but I'm like, bruv.
Stand on the stand when she's not looking.
Right, if Mercy's distracting her.
Okay, I've stood on the stand.
While she's not looking, I am doing no input.
As if that was it.
That took us so long to get the first thing.
Right, he's got tea in his hand.
I need to ring the bell.
Look at me.
I'm Mercy.
I have a bow.
Ready?
Yes!
Oh my God.
That's fantastic.
It took us so long to get one and now we have two.
Oh, now you have such a cool ribbon on you.
I know.
I have a bow like you now.
The soap.
What do we do with the soap?
Why do you have soap outside?
Well, she has like a bathtub and a toilet.
Quite literally is her decorative stuff.
Hold on.
Let me check where our objectives are
because I've completely forgotten that.
Oh, sorry, that's not objectives.
Make the man go barefoot and do the washing
with a bra, a pair of socks, slippers and a bar soap.
Right, hold on a minute.
Where would we do washing?
Right, I'm going to steal this guy's other loafer.
But where do we get water to do the washing?
Let's steal his shoe because that's super easy.
Hello, we would like to steal your shoe, please.
We do the washing in here.
No, it's not what it looks like.
We're not here for your other loafer at all, I promise.
I promise.
You can't get me.
Out of bounds.
Talk to the game devs because the face ain't listening.
Okay.
Oh, he won't let me in again.
Right, okay.
Well, go sit back down.
Because now we need to do laundry.
I don't really know where to do laundry.
Put the vase on the man's side of the garden.
The man will throw it back over.
Oh, we're just straight up getting spoiled.
Are you okay if we get our hand held?
Because I don't mind the wreaths and spoiling it for me.
Okay, we need to drag the purple statue all the way over.
We're back.
We can do it.
Don't mind me.
I'm strapped.
I'm not that fast, lady.
There you go.
I'm stuck on the fence.
Let me over.
Okay, we did it.
Yay.
Hello, would you like to throw this magnificent priceless vase over the fence by any chance?
Or vase vase?
I don't know.
Vase?
Like Vaseline?
He actually did.
Oh, he's going to go the other way.
Wait, why are you taking me?
He just stripped me naked.
Give me back.
I'm naked.
I feel so humiliated.
Oh, I guess we do the washing in here.
Oh, okay.
Because look, there's water.
Oh my God, we're swimming.
Wait, we need to grab the bar.
We need the bra and the sockies.
Can I quickly grab it this way?
Maybe I can run.
No, no.
Let's do it this way.
If she catches me, it's fine because at least you've got...
Wait, she's not even upset about the...
Okay, we're doing it.
We're doing it.
Turns out all we needed was someone to spell it out for us.
Wait, no, he's not going to throw that back over.
It's in the water now.
No, this is mine.
It's in the water.
No, no, no, no, no.
Don't do something.
Give me that.
It's going in the water for washes.
Yeah, that's right.
You don't want to stand in this.
No, these are mine.
There are many things.
No, go have your tea.
Why aren't you drinking tea a moment ago?
Go forget.
Forget?
No, no, no, no.
Hold on.
No.
Leave Mercy be, you fellow wench.
Harlan!
Yes, please listen to my problems.
Suzuki, life is so hard as a ghost.
You see, people don't...
Oh, well, you are.
As long as one of us picks up, that's the main thing.
Grab it.
I'm away.
I'll grab her stuff.
No, no, no, no.
Stop what it looks like.
I promise it's not.
Right, hold on.
There.
I know your neighbor's with that again.
Ah.
Take this sock.
Can you pick up that bar of soap?
That's on the bathtub?
Yeah.
And then we...
I think we're done.
I think we've done it.
Yeah.
Taking the clothes.
Right, as long as the guy doesn't take a random pair of socks off of us,
I don't know why he would care that much,
but I don't know where he is.
And the camera isn't zoomed out,
so I don't know if I'm going to run into him.
Is he still...
Oh, he's moved the bra out of the freaking thing.
Right, let me go get that bra.
Do not throw that bra over the fence.
Do you understand me?
Give me that bra.
Give me that bra to me.
I need that.
I need my training bra, okay?
We're doing laundry.
Is this what I'm supposed to do?
La, la, la, la, la.
Wait, this wasn't what I was supposed to do.
What is...
Do the washing.
A slipper!
Oh, no, I'll put all the slippers out of bounds.
Oh, no, I'm backfired.
My plan has backfired terrifically.
Hold on.
Hold the line, Mercy.
Hold the line.
I'm coming, Mercy.
Distract him.
No, no, no, no.
Oh, hold the line.
Hold the line.
I'm coming.
Oh, hold the line.
Oh, I'm running.
I'm running.
Oh!
Yes!
Yay!
We did it!
That was frickin' hard.
You didn't make it so hard.
God, that camera is so hard.
To-do list.
Make someone print...
The prize, right?
The prize.
I mean, it looks like he wants to do it.
I'm not really wanting to, like, make him do anything.
What is he writing?
Does that mean he just, like, honk when he's, you know...
Oh, he hit me.
Did he make a no-geese sign?
I think everyone's...
Yeah, literally everyone's doing a no-geese every time we're finished in an area.
Okay, do this.
Right, he can touch the brand stuff.
It doesn't matter.
How do we...
Is there any gardening equipment?
Oh, yeah.
You just closed it on my face, lady.
Don't do that again.
That made myself clear.
Is there gardening tools in here?
Hello, lady.
Do you have a...
The shears?
Oh!
I see it.
And I'm messing it up terribly.
Oh, this is quite heavy.
I have to...
Hold on, lady.
Give me that.
See this paint?
Man, I'm terrible at this game.
You know that.
Can you grab those clippers?
Yeah, I'm just gonna...
Excuse me.
Have you ever heard about our savior, Goose McGooseface?
Very good Goose.
One of the best Goose that lived for seven years, which is so big in Goose life.
It is...
Thank you for listening to my story.
Is that how you print a rose bush?
Well, we're giving them...
We...
Do we need to...
Oh, I need to move it.
Oh, yeah.
Huh?
That didn't do anything.
Do we need...
Is there a rose bush we need to, like, steal from her garden?
Grab the rose pot and drag it next to the shrub, then mess up the shrub.
Mess up the shrub.
Excuse me, lady.
You need to come back in your garden.
Man, fuck the shrub.
Fuck the shrub.
You know that Nicki Minaj song that's like, hi heels on Nicki?
Wait, wait, wait.
And it goes, fuck the club.
Fuck the...
Yeah, fuck the shrub.
Is that all?
I mean, I'm going for it.
Wait, he threw the things...
Wait, is she going to accidentally chop off the rose?
Yeah, looks like she is.
Uh...
She hid it behind her back.
Oh, no.
Do you know how long it takes to make roses?
It's like a very hard job to have them grow successfully.
It takes so long.
Right, okay, let's see.
We caused a...
We caused a problem.
Oh, no, he's...
Is he crying?
He said my rose.
He shits the rose, revenge.
Right, how do we get out of here?
Oh, what's she doing?
She's opening a panel.
She's letting us go out this panel here.
She said I had enough of you, geese.
Sorry, are we in the way?
Pardon me, lady.
I don't know what your plan is.
Oh, she got no geese as well.
Okay, I actually kind of like that when you're finished with this section,
the game's like no goose, by the way.
No geese.
Okay, okay, I'm out.
I'm out.
Jeez, I'm done.
Yay.
Okay, bye.
Thank you, lady.
What's in here?
Hello.
Oh, pardon...
Oh, sorry, I'm just here to bring...
Oh, we're just coming through.
Sorry, just visiting.
Oh, package.
Thank you.
Whose package is this?
Can we open it?
We can take it away with us.
We actually don't have an objective, so we're not there yet.
Is this the wrong way?
I like to steal people's mail.
I'm a porch pirate.
Look at me.
Yarg.
I'm going to post it in the wrong door on purpose.
I'm going to put this one on the other person's door.
Yeah, yeah.
And then they get to talk and then they'll fall in love or something.
Yeah, well, we're so good.
We're such good neighbors.
Okay, I literally...
We need geese everywhere.
Geese are actually secretly keepers.
You're so helpful.
We're writing fan fiction.
Look at the lavender.
Pretty flowers.
We love flowers in this house.
You're the prettiest flower I've ever seen.
Oh, it's juff.
I'm blushing.
Oh, the camera angle is swapping every two seconds.
Oh my God, there's a Benki!
AC is in this game!
Not this!
Look at the Benki!
It's for AC!
Oh my God, it's for Benki!
Wait, AC needs to play this game now just so she can walk around.
Look, you're so cute now.
Wait, how do I do AC's voice again?
On today, we're going to play Goose Game with Mercy.
Thank you, OGSans, for watching me and my kohai, Mercy and the snippets.
This is a terrible voice.
I cannot do AC at all.
I'm trying, okay?
I can't do AC.
AC is too unique and too cute.
Can't do it like a European accent?
Is it too hard to mimic European accents?
Of any kind.
Can you do French?
Did you learn French because you know,
I didn't really learn French.
Bonjour, salut.
Like that kind of French.
Oh, I've not heard your French voice!
I've not heard your French voice before!
Salut, merci, a va?
a va bien.
Wow, your French voice is so cute!
To jouer avec moi, on...
Oh, we're at the meeting again!
Look, it's the rake!
Wait, are we done?
Did we finish already?
No, we couldn't have.
No, we've not.
Help the woman dress up the boss.
Oh no, did we...
Wait, no, but she let us go to the next area, so...
Are we finished?
Oh no!
Oh, it makes the ground keepers wear his own hat.
We don't have that.
But we're allowed to move on?
How do we make...
You accidentally went back to the beginning of the game.
Wait, so we need to go the other way to unlock the new map?
Hold on, Ray, let's try the other...
Only we would manage that, honestly.
Ray, let's try that again.
Let's try that again, Ray.
We'll go upstream this time.
It was the French, I'll burn the French this time.
I don't know where the fuck we is.
Wait, do we need to go along that bridge there?
No, maybe.
I'm swimming up the water.
To say water in French, you say...
L'eau.
Why is the French...
Why is water male in French?
I do not know.
No.
Can we eat?
I'm skinny buying that skinny, you know what I'm saying?
You think where it matters.
Yeah, exactly.
That's what I like to hear.
Wait, so...
We're casually just flirting.
I remember seeing complaints like...
On feature group collabs, I was just turned into them being nice to each other.
What, you're surprised?
You're surprised that we're nice?
What do you want me mean?
Yeah, literally Scots?
What do you want me to be like?
Oh, you Canadians with your cube costs and all that,
and your fake French, like what?
Wait, so we weren't supposed to go here or...
I thought this was a nice area to go to.
What's the deal?
This was the way to go, because we opened a gate to get here,
and there was a new camera angle.
Oh, well, I guess we should move this way now.
Moving on up?
Maybe it was like a shortcut to go back, I guess?
A bit of Bologna.
Okay, well, considering...
Yeah, there's literally an arrow that's like...
You're actually meant to go this way, dumbass.
Oh, hey, a car.
Let's trap someone in it.
Oh.
So this is how Mercy lured her first victim.
This is how I heard my first victim, right, Senpai?
I put in, like, hot girls in your area in this truck,
and you just walked in.
I can't believe you guys actually responded to that ad.
She put up cute Yandere in your area,
seeking you now two miles away.
She's honing in on your current location.
Wait a minute.
Whatever objectives.
Get into the pub.
Break the dartboard.
Get the toy boat.
Can you say toy boat ten times?
Fast?
Toy boat?
Why?
Toy boat, toy boat, toy boat, toy boat, toy boat, toy boat, toy boat, toy boat, toy boat, toy boat, toy boat, toy boat, toy boat, toy boat, toy boat.
Wait, why does it sound like something's on there?
Oh, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Toy boat, hey, how do you say toy boat?
Toy boat.
Toy boat, toy boat.
Bit of a toy boat moment.
Bit of a toy boat.
Like when you say, like, tin soldier or something,
and then you're supposed to say it like ten times fast or something.
Tin soldier? I've never heard tin soldier, tin soldier, tin soldier.
Oh, tin soldier, tin soldier, tin soldier, tin soldier, tin soldier, tin soldier, tin soldier.
Okay, okay, I've not heard that one.
I heard like Peter Piper picked a pick.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Can you get his shoes? I want your shoes.
Oh, go for his laces.
Get him where it hurts.
Give me that.
Yeah.
We're terrorizing him.
Oh, I can't.
This camera angle is so unforgiven.
It really is.
No, I keep getting pushed away.
Do we need to jump in the van and scare them?
Jump in the box, maybe.
You're right.
There should be another box in the van.
Let's go into your secret kidnap van.
Wait, how do we...
We get in the...
How do I...
How do you...
Okay, wait.
Oh, no.
It's only one at a time, right?
You go in before me.
I'll be fine.
You go in without me.
It's okay. We'll cause trouble with leaders.
Yes, I think if you burst out of the box, maybe.
One of you hide in the box when the woman isn't looking,
close the box and wait until the delivery woman picks up the box,
she will carry you inside the pub.
What about me? I'll just stay outside.
I'm literally waiting in line for a queue.
I'm pretty sure people have to queue for nightclubs or something like that.
I'm queuing to get in the pub right now.
I've been to clubs a few times,
and I'm just like,
that's loud music.
It's not for me, mate.
Oh!
I got these Tism earphones
where you put in and it makes everything quieter when you go outside.
If you do not have them, they are so good.
I cannot recommend them enough.
I will literally send you a pair.
It makes going outside a heck of a lot easier.
Oh!
Yes.
Be careful. That's goods in there.
That's very valuable goods.
Do I make myself clear?
Okay.
There should be another box.
Am I going to...
Is the camera going to thingy out?
Oh no.
Can you see yourself?
I can't move. I'm stuck.
I'm stuck too.
Did the game devs...
Game devs? Hello game devs?
Any game devs?
Any hotpatch? Any game dev fixers?
That is not good.
I'm not sure.
I think we might have softlocked ourselves a little bit.
I'm not...
I'm stuck.
Game bro! Game bro!
I'm in! I'm in!
That wasn't very nice of me. Where are you?
I don't know.
Oh no!
Where's the grid?
Mild panic.
How on earth do I get to you?
There's a hole in here.
Yeah. What do you call me?
Oh where is it?
I'm reunited.
It feels so good.
Yunk yunk.
Okay let's destroy that dartboard.
Oh yeah! Actually we need to play...
Bullseye!
190!
Oh no no! We're just...
We're niceki's.
We're niceki's I promise.
We're not... Oh we have little...
Game...
All the toss the ring stuff.
Oh sorry. Were you playing that?
Oh sorry. Were you playing?
Yeah I think I...
Oh that's the dart!
That scream out on when he...
One, two, three!
Oh.
I'm sorry for distracting you, Gitzer.
How do we destroy that?
Oh no I'm sorry!
I get to play all harmonica!
Hmm.
How do we destroy a dartboard between us?
Maybe cigarette?
Maybe we've got something similar?
Hmm.
Yeah.
Oh! There's like a little podium!
I knight myself the geese of old...
Is it a podium?
Are they clapping for me?
Hello?
How do you open your wings?
I don't know.
Oh my god!
They love us!
I was joking about this being a podium!
But we actually got a flower!
That's so cute!
Oh my god we're such good kids!
We should join a circus.
Yes we should join a circus.
What?
Oh that's so cute.
Okay maybe geese girl considered for Gen 2
because of how adorable these are.
I'm starting to warm up to anyone...
Suggestion to a wasp girl.
A what?
Oh see bug girls are an issue
and I'll tell you why I actually developed
mental, I don't mind telling you this.
Oh really?
Because of arachnophobia for example
or insectphobia is a very real thing.
It has a possibility
of putting the girl at a disadvantage.
Design wise.
Yeah!
If you didn't know
I don't mind sharing this with you.
But you know how you have...
Oh that's nice.
Oh that's it?
That's it no more?
Oh my god give them the flower!
You were amazing!
Oh I can't give them the flower
he doesn't like it.
You were amazing sir!
You wanna play again?
Mister?
No he just wants to look at us.
That's fine.
So you know how you have
two eyeballs?
Yeah.
I made sure
you had two eyeballs because
it's actually really startling
if a vtuber only has
one eye or is like a mono eye
monster girl type thing.
It's kind of one of the
rules of like
development is you can't
wait can she see me under the table?
You must have a girl
with two eyes that isn't too freaky
or you're putting them at a severe disadvantage.
It kind of goes the same
for vtubers that might have
multiple eye designs.
It's
unfortunately just like
a weird unwritten rule you're not supposed to do it.
What is going on over here?
Are we doing the dishes?
Oh it's the balls!
Oh it's the toy!
Ah! Hide under table!
Hide under table! Oh no there's no table over here!
Leave us alone!
Leave me alone I'm scared!
I'm just a little guy
who wants a knife!
Hold on I want this knife.
Hold on let me go on.
Oh wow she's like chasing me all the way out.
Chase me under the table good luck with that.
You look very menacing with
a knife in your mouth!
Oh the knife is underneath you I think.
What am I to do with a knife?
I don't know I felt like maybe we can destroy
the dartboard with the knife.
Break the dartboard get the toy boat
make the old man fall on his bottom
steal a pint glass
and drop it in a canal
and set the table knife fork plate
Oh.
Set what table?
I'm like proper stuck.
Oh what's this?
I'm currently getting gridlocked
mildly gridlocked.
Where are we supposed to set up a table?
I don't know.
Oh there's like a little underway pathway here.
I mean a bug girl doesn't need
multiple eyes.
It's kind of hard to like
Oh my god I'm like
Sorry Mercy's currently fighting
the owner and I'm like under here like
Well actually when it comes to the designs
and intricateness of having to produce
Emma. Oh no don't shim me I was saying.
You can't get me when I'm under
the dock.
Continue.
What table
are we supposed to set up?
Wait we're meant to make him fall
on his bottom. Oh when he goes
to play the harmonic we need to move
the chair out of the way.
Oh that's sad.
I don't know I know he seems a bit too old
for this.
Yeah he's literally already says oh my back hurts.
How do we break
a dart board truly?
Maybe we take a knife and then
he throws the knife instead.
Is this one supposed to do it?
No he notices as soon as
I take it.
Right so then what's the table we
can you pick up the dart?
You can.
Bunk.
I don't
I don't know.
I wanted to play too sir.
What the deal is
reeflings you're going to have to
hold my hand I don't know what we're
doing.
Oh no no no it's all good
it's all good.
Uh
this is Scalera
lens type thing.
So when he goes to play the harmonica
so basically we have to watch him play
darts and then he grabs the harmonica.
The table is in the back of the pub
where Mercy got stuck at.
We need to set a table whilst that person
chases us around.
That's severe.
Biblically accurate
Vita for Angel that's actually quite funny.
Yeah
well you you didn't get a bullseye
but that's okay.
Move out of the way.
I wasn't doing anything.
Yeah yeah.
Oh
I feel so bad now.
Okay he actually recovered from
Oh no he didn't.
No we're sorry.
I wasn't really
at our attention but we got it done.
Right we need to set a table
up here.
I'm setting a table.
Table table table. What table?
Table. This table?
That table.
The table that
Mercy got stuck at.
This one? Why yes.
I am aware of a table Mercy got stuck
at. This one? Surely.
I don't
I don't see any.
The candlestick one.
I've been able to pick up the candlestick though.
You can't do that with this.
I don't
leave me alone. I'm just a little goose
in a human world.
Not there.
It is back lift.
Follow the path under the deck
to get to the back.
Wait
where Mercy got taken and I couldn't reach?
Oh
Oh my god.
Okay.
Let's get these items.
You're chasing me out.
Yes shoot shoot. We're out of the cafe.
Go away and go do
your cafe stuff.
Exactly. I'm going to grab some stuff.
I'm going to grab anything I can.
I got the cup for the table.
Are you going to grab something too?
Are you feeling risky?
I'm going to get chased out.
I broke it.
Oopsies.
Don't chase me out. I need to pick up an item
for the table.
That's right. I'm hiding under the table.
I'm off camera.
I'm out. Sorry.
It's fine. Pick up that candle.
You can pick up that candlestick I think.
I want to get the candlestick
but I'm stuck now.
I'm stuck as well.
This freaking video.
The distance thing.
Oh my god. I'm getting
pushed out by the guard as well.
Ring the guards.
This is the best I can do. Literally be right under you.
They did not make this game easy.
We're two players.
Sorry.
Stop chasing me.
How is he chasing you out like this?
We're literally
all the way inside the restaurant.
Did the old man
tell them?
No. Stop looking at me.
He is
honing in on you. Can you come under the deck?
I'm going to try to come under the deck.
No.
Okay. You're safe.
He should go away. Yeah. He said,
oh. Rassen for Rassen.
And he's going to go get a beer.
No.
He instantly locks on you.
How did he know?
That doesn't seem right.
That seems too difficult.
Follow the...
He's so persistent.
Poor man can't catch a break.
Wait. He's looking for his glass but I broke it.
Wait. There's now two people in the cafe area.
We need
so much stuff from it.
Hi.
Does he give up?
I hope he gives up. Damn.
Yeah. Is there anything we can do on this side?
I don't think so. I can see the goose sign
here. They're going to move it right here.
This sign right here. That's the no goose sign.
I can tell. I have gamer instinct.
There's a plate over here.
Wait. There's already a plate here?
There is.
Okay. We'll take that and then
we'll start getting it set up. Is there anything else
I can grab? What's this?
That's a bucket.
Wait.
I hope I don't break it.
No. I don't... Yeah.
Yeah.
It's so painy.
What?
Oh, my face.
My face! Ow!
My little goose neck just got
snapped in half. I can't believe he closed down
your face.
So red.
So what is...
We're like...
How do you describe the dart bird?
I am...
Right. I'm going to get the salt shaker.
Yeah. Get the salt shaker.
Give me this. Give me this.
Okay. I said give me this.
There we go. Right. And then I'll go on to the table
with you and then I'll go down the steps
and then I can put it on the little table thing.
And then that's one more. I am ticked off
of this. Yeah. Jeez. She is
feral for us right now.
I'm following. I'm following.
Is there emotion sickness levels
question mark? Oh, bad.
Because the camera keeps moving, but...
Okay. Do we need to pause?
We can always...
I'm very sad.
I think we've had a good game insertion.
We do not actually have to... Yeah, I don't want you
to actually be sick
by this game.
If it's too much, please don't be afraid to say no
because I can literally mean and chat
and ask questions and stuff.
I'm trying. I'm trying to
get through it.
Okay. How about we finish this
goofy level and then maybe call it
there because I don't want you to be sick.
Yeah. Is she going to be bothered?
Yeah. Okay. Well, great.
Right. Let's just check the list to make sure
we need to steal
a glass paint
and drop it in the canal. I don't even know
where that is. We just need a knife, a fork,
and a candle. Okay.
Don't worry. There's a candle there.
Okay.
Oh, she's right there again.
Oh, that camera angle.
She doesn't bother with us. Does she?
No, she's just happy.
She's like, what a curiosity.
You're breaking up my day.
Thank you, little geese for showing up.
I was like, oh, you're welcome. Right. Where is this
fork?
Sugar.
She's going to see me.
No, no, no, no, no. You don't see me.
I am a mystery.
Oh, metal bones.
No, no, don't push me that way.
Mercy's that way.
I'm getting pushed out.
I'm literally getting pushed out of the camera.
I can't bring you closer to the stairs.
That's okay.
I'm trying to grab the knife.
Game devs, you really
have done yourself with this one.
I think I'm getting shoved.
I know you're stuck.
I am complete. I can't even see myself.
Hold on. Hold on.
Hold on. Here we go.
Wait, hold on.
I need to snipe his shoes, basically.
Okay.
This isn't...
Development team.
You need a hand?
Yes. Go, tie your lace
as it's dangerous to go.
Wait, I can't even get past?
Bro, you ain't even got...
The whole mechanic was that he...
You take your shoes off.
I'm being trolled so hard this game.
Hold on. Let me just move underneath.
No, never mind. I'm out of bounds now.
Yeah, it keeps...
I can't even get past. Okay, there we go.
Oh, we did it. We did it. We did it.
Go, go, go.
No, no, no, don't send me out again.
Don't send me out of bounds again.
Oh, it doesn't matter because he's chasing you.
No, I want my knife.
Well, one of us can...
I've taken the knife.
The knife.
Oh, no, no, he's got you.
Well, sorry, I'm running.
Pick up the knife, please.
Okay, there we go. I got it. I got it. I got the knife.
Run.
Okay, we did it.
My controls are not nice.
Help!
I can't even see you.
I can't even see me!
Wait, the guy doesn't respond
to honking at all?
He doesn't care!
No!
Oh, he sucks.
I don't like him.
Oh, no, I have made a grave error.
Go, I need to go underneath
or above either one.
No, I'm getting pushed out.
He's such a bully.
Oh, well, I can just sneak over.
Can you maybe run, please?
Nice lady.
I can't hear until he stops being aggressive on us.
He is like the worst.
Yeah, darn it.
He's not having any of it.
No, no, wait, he shouldn't know where it is.
I left it on the other side of the fence
at the table
that we set up so it should be fine.
Our knife is...
Yeah, go away, mister.
Go, go away, mister.
Literally, he's so aggressive against us.
This is discrimination.
I'll be talking to the BBC.
Exactly.
I'll be doing a report.
I'll be getting interviewers out here
so everyone can learn of your dastardly...
Right.
Hide under the table.
What's this?
What is it?
I don't know, but...
I'm pulling.
Oh my god, it's how I get a beer.
Wait, but I don't have a glass.
Sugar.
Well, I've got a fork.
We need to fork anyway.
Let me get out of here with this fork.
I don't know where the glass of beer is, though.
I'm underneath, so she can't get me.
I think we broke it.
We did.
So how on earth did we get...
Well, I did.
Um...
Ah, I knocked it over.
No, no, it's okay. I think it still counts.
As long as it's on the table, I think it counts.
Wow, I'm doing a little 360.
All right, it says...
A knife and a candle. We actually do have a knife.
Oh. Right, we just need a candle.
We've done this really awkward part.
Why won't it stand?
Okay, let's do this approach.
There we go.
Or do we have to, like, actually set it...
Like, the fork goes on the left.
The knife goes on the right type stuff.
Nah, they wouldn't put that in the game.
They wouldn't put that, right?
I feel like that's, like...
How do you know your knowledge?
Well, I cannot pick up the fork.
Is it glitched out?
It says the fork is there. Okay.
It still counts. We've got to get the candle now.
This is the candle.
And then we're done this terrible back and forth section, I think.
Where was the... Hello.
Hi. Oh, sorry.
I'm sorry. I didn't mean to be in your way.
Wait, she's pushing me out of the way.
Stinky.
You want to give me all the attention, lady, don't you?
Yes, you do.
Where did she put the candle?
Is that the best paper again?
It may be.
I'm just a goose getting all the attention.
For no... Oh, I'm stuck on her.
For no particular...
I'll go under the deck.
Yes.
Oh, sugar. Okay.
You got it.
I don't know where she...
Oh, my game. My game just closed.
Whoa! However, I think you're going to have to come
down these stairs and then come underneath with me here.
If I don't get chased out, yes.
Yeah, come this way, this way.
No, no, no, no!
Go, go, go, go, go, go!
Send it, send it, send it!
Okay, okay, I think it's okay.
I think it's okay.
I've got the candlestick.
Oh, no.
That's the main thing. As long as we got the candlestick,
I can get you back in.
All you have to do is unpeel as we...
Yeah, you're not coming under here.
Oh, wait, why did I hit her?
Uh, you might be able to get past...
Yeah, you can get back in
if I distract him enough.
And then come under here with me.
No!
This guy sucks!
Oh!
It controls, it controls.
Okay, we're safe, we're safe.
The heat is now off of us.
Oh, you can see my little red flippers.
I like my little flip-flops.
Okay, he has gone back.
I think we can now go to the wee restaurant.
The wee restaurant.
I'm stuck on something.
We casually scroll in.
You're stuck?
I'm like getting stuck on stuff.
There we go.
I don't know.
Okay, there we go.
Wee!
We finally frickin' did it!
This one was not easy.
I think it's the control and the camera.
Yeah, this camera angle
is spinning around every two seconds.
Oh, I'm stuck again.
Oh my gosh, I'm so sorry.
Is that vomit burp?
I'm getting nervous.
It was the motion sickness burp.
I'm so sorry, excuse me.
Actually, we can stop.
I didn't know when you just hop on our first collab.
Because we picked up this motion.
Okay, if that was a vomit burp,
I'm happy to say we have set the table.
Yeah, we set the table.
Okay, I am not going to make you play anymore.
I really do not.
Any issues?
Okay.
We will say thank you so so much
for letting us have
an absolute carry on.
Unfortunately, we thank you.
I stupendously
asked her to
play a motion sickness
and juicing game. I had no idea
that the camera angle was so violent
towards her, per mercy.
But I think
I'm happy to say we'll end it there.
I don't want any vomit.
Okay, that's the bottom line.
No vomit please.
I'm sorry.
No, don't be sorry.
I was like, oh, it was so good.
I haven't burped yet on stream.
Oops.
We'll play it safe.
Please do not worry. Let's play nice and safe.
We will say to the snippets
and the reeflings. Thank you so so much
for watching.
I am streaming again tomorrow.
Merci. Are you streaming tomorrow?
Is the real question?
No, I place my day off.
Well, I'll put her to work
lads. Don't you worry.
I'll make an ASMR for her to put her to work.
Don't you worry about that.
Teasing. Teasing.
She'll have a break.
We will leave it there
and I'm going to let you know
that we're going to be playing
a motion sickness game.
We'll leave it there
and I'm going to let Merci lie down
because I think she needs a good nap
or maybe a big lie down
and some fizzy juice to help her feel a bit better.
But thank you so so much
for joining me, Merci. I appreciate that so much.
And that was actually genuinely really fun.
So much fun.
As chaotic as that game was,
that was actually hilarious that you
started controlling my goose.
Wow, yandere powers.
Literally.
That was supposed to be that most of this one here.
Right. Thank you so so much.
Thank you everyone.
I'm going to end a little strum.
Oh wait, no, no one's streaming
because you're the one that normally streams lads.
Should I?
Let's see if there's someone on you.
Let me check with one of the girls.
Let me check if I can find it.
Azura rated it in a U.S.
That means she finished her cheeky stream,
her cheeky bricky stream.
There are some girls
on. There's Rain
from Ume Plus
and a bunch of
VNU girls are on too.
I have not
I will do Rae from
Thingy because I don't think she's monetized yet.
She will watch Time.
Yeah, let's Rae into Rain.
I will Rae into Rae. She's doing
unicorn overload, number two,
shipping characters to fight better.
This one's like a
vanilla wear game.
It's supposed to be really good.
Have you played it before?
No, I haven't.
But I'm a fan of vanilla wear
games.
That's cute.
Thank you so much, Sneeflings.
Thank you so much, Mersey, for joining me.
Please do get some serious rest
because I do not want any.
How terrible is that headline?
Collab
results in like vomit.
What kind of collab is going on
if that's the case?
Thank you.
I missed some soupas.
Thank you so much.
Misaka best for the
420 blazes.
Stop goose hate. Thank you so much
for the tip you with me.
Thank you.
For the five dollar
super chat. Did you know Rick
Ashley is never going to give you up.
Never going to let you down.
Never going to let you down
twice. Never going to run around
and desert you. Yes, I knew that.
Thank you so much for the five.
Wow.
Thank you so much, everyone
for such a wonderful stream
and thank you.
It was unexpected that
we hit such a
dizzy game.
We got so close though,
but I would not have picked that game
had I known how spinny camera it was.
I thought it was
a straightforward linear
experience. So I do apologize for that
oversight, Mercy. It's okay.
Honestly, everything looked
like it was going to be fine, but like
yeah, that was
every time we entered or moved around
somewhere, the camera just like violently
spins over.
Sorry to anyone that also has
motion sickness watching. You probably feel like
right now.
Okay.
Right.
I will let you get going.
Thank you so much, Mercy.
Let's put it to the end stream
and then we're right into rain.
Yeah. Yes.
Okay, I'm end streamed. Bye bye, replays.
Bye bye.
In the broadcast.
Successfully.